c'est un cauchemar je vis un cauchemar
quelqu'un de très important
financièrement d'ailleurs il me fait
énormément de chantage avec ça en me
disant constamment je suis un homme de
pouvoir j'ai une armée d'avocat j'ai
beaucoup d'argent tu ne feras pas le
poids je vais t'enlever l'enfant de
toute façon ta seule faiblesse et
l'enfant donc je vais te l'enlever
désormais tu verras ton à l'avenir tu
verras ton enfant qu'avec des gardes du
corps Vincent a des comptes à régler
avec moi ce n'est pas une histoire de
d'enfants il peut voir son enfant quand
il le souhaite c'est un règlement de
compte personnel c'est un homme de
pouvoir comme il aime le dire à qui on
ne dit pas non et à qui on ne refuse
rien ça fait cinq ans que ça dure les
procédures et qui me fait des menaces et
qui me fait du chantage et de la
pression psychologique et de
l'harcèlement psychologique d'ailleurs
je me demande encore même comment je me
suis pas encore suicidé avec tout ce qui
me fait je suis épuisée je n'ai besoin
de la peine et de la pitié de personne
je voudrais juste qu'on me laisse
rentrer tranquillement avec mon fils je
me battrai jusqu'au bout et je ne
repartirai pas sans mon fils